not too long ago nfts were the hottest
commodity on the market we saw singers
athletes youtubers and even comedians
buy into the craze these guys were
dropping hundreds of thousands if not
millions of dollars on these
non-fungible tokens
and while non-fungible tokens might
sound like some sort of fancy investment
in the end it's really just a digital
picture
in fact unless you told someone they
wouldn't even know whether you paid for
the picture or not
but with that being said at least the
celebrities could afford it did you
taught me what's up and then i bought an
ape i got an ape too because i saw you
on the show with people and you said you
got a moonpay so i went and i copied you
and did the same thing usually these
guys are worth tens of millions if not
hundreds of millions so losing a few
hundred thousand or even a few million
wouldn't drastically change their lives
but these guys weren't the only ones
that were buying into the craze
loads of retail traders were sinking
their life savings into dozens of jpegs
hoping that at least one of them would
become the next crypto punk or board ape
but as the entire market started to
crash it didn't take long for nfts to
follow for example in april board apes
were selling for four hundred to five
hundred thousand dollars but now they're
selling for just over a hundred thousand
similarly crypto punks have also crashed
from over four hundred thousand dollars
to under a hundred thousand dollars and
these are the most prominent and notable
nfts many of the nfts that everyday
people were buying are down over 90 from
their all-time highs which is not that
surprising given that nfd sales have
crashed 92 percent from their peak but
how did this entire craze even start and
will nfts ever recover
well taking a look back the idea of nfts
has actually been around for quite some
time dating all the way back to 2012. at
the time a man named manny rosenfield
published a white paper called colored
coins the paper described a method in
which real world assets could be
represented and accounted for in the
digital world the idea was to create
tokens that were similar to bitcoins in
that transactions would be accounted for
on the blockchain but the difference was
that each token would be unique and
distinguish ebola unlike bitcoin while
this was a rather interesting idea to
many crypto enthusiasts the idea
couldn't really be implemented due to
limitations with bitcoin this didn't
stop enthusiasts from trying to make
colored coins a reality though and that
brings us to an artist named kevin mccoy
in 2014 kevin created a piece of digital
art called quantum quantum was a simple
piece it was basically just an octagon
that was pulsating in different colors
but what made it unique was kevin's
effort to make it into an nft
since he couldn't leverage bitcoin he
launched quantum on a secondary
blockchain called namecoin which made
quantum the world's first nft i don't
think you'd be surprised here that
quantum was sold for well over a million
dollars at the peak
anyway after the release of quantum we
saw a lot of buzz in the crypto
community surrounding nfts there was a
lot of hype surrounding native support
for nfts from bitcoin but this never
really happened
even today the bitcoin blockchain does
not natively support nfts the problem is
that bitcoin wasn't built with real
assets in mind so trying to inject this
new idea into bitcoin is rather
difficult but this is where ethereum
comes in ethereum wasn't launched until
mid-2015 so the development team had
quite a bit of time to study the
shortfalls of bitcoin and address them
the ethereum team and didn't support
nfts directly per se but they built a
robust system of smart contracts which
made creating it minting it and
distributing nfts easier than ever
before and this ease caught the
attention of two software developers
named john watkinson and matt hall who
decided to create their own set of nfts
they launched this experimental nfp
project with the 10 000 pieces that were
inspired by london's punk culture and
they decided to call them crypto punks
initially they actually handed out
crypto punks for free to anyone with an
ethereum wallet this is quite ironic
given that each of these would
eventually be worth over four hundred
thousand dollars anyway since then
crypto punks have become an og within
the nft space and we've seen thousands
of projects try to replicate their
success but only a few have even come
close such as the board apes in the
meantime crypto exchanges were also hard
at work trying to make it as easy as
possible for everyday people to buy and
trade nfts and that brings us into the
insanity that we saw last year
hearing the history of nfts probably
didn't convince most of you guys that
nfts are useful by any means
after all it's basically just a couple
of art collections going viral with the
help of blockchain technology but
digital art is just one use case for
nfts and it's actually the most
overrated use case nfts have several
other use cases such as proof of
ownership you see nfds aren't limited to
just proving ownership of digital art
they can be used to prove the ownership
of anything and a great example is real
estate imagine if you got an nfd based
deed when you bought a house you could
essentially create a record of the
home's occupancy and ownership on the
blockchain and when you're ready to sell
the house you could easily show
potential buyers the entire history of
the home the day it was built combine
this with smart contracts and you can
eliminate much of the paperwork and
tediousness associated with real estate
transactions altogether this same
principle applies to anything with
substantial value
what if you got an nft along with
corporations stock investments bond
investments and so on and so forth nfts
aren't just limited to high value items
either nfts could also be implemented
into everyday items like groceries and
food in this scenario nfts would have
less to do with proving ownership and
more to do with keeping track of the
supply chain after all i don't think the
average person cares about having a
digital certificate that proves that
they own the milk in their fridge
however if milk came with an nft people
could track down what farm it came from
this is a pretty cool idea but i bet the
average person would probably get over
it within a week where this really makes
sense is large companies with complex
supply chains companies like apple and
tesla can leverage nfts to maintain a
detailed log of the origins of their
steel and lithium and aluminum and so on
and with all the supply chain problems
we've been facing the need for such a
system is more evident than ever putting
the business world aside nfts also prove
quite valuable when it comes to records
and credentials what if birth
certificates medical records passports
and driver's licenses were all securely
stored on the blockchain you wouldn't
have to worry about keeping all these
documents safe or logging them around to
hospitals and the dmv a similar case
could be made for credentials as well
when you graduate college you can get an
nft that goes along with your diploma
this would make it easier for employers
to verify your academic background
similar nfts could be handed out to
licensed electricians plumbers and car
printers this way when you hire a
contractor you can ensure that they
actually know what they're doing they
can be used to validate tickets and
patents and voting and so much more so
don't be fooled by the apparently
useless jpegs that are being circulated
around social media the real
applications of nfts are far greater
than apes and flexing
while nfds do have quite a bit of
potential the current crash that we're
experiencing it is well warranted and
way overdue
as elon musk puts it it's been raining
money unfolds for too long and this is
what's given nft such a terrible
reputation in the first place
when people think of nfts they don't
think about how it could revolutionize
proof of ownership or how it could help
create digital records and
certifications
rather they think about larger
celebrities dumping obscene amounts of
money into pictures that you can
screenshot off of google and as long as
people are making millions flipping
jpegs this will be the overwhelming
narrative surrounding nfts not to
mention it there's the whole scamming
side of it as well we've seen hundreds
of fake nft websites that try to
replicate legitimate nfd marketplaces
and the people end up spending tens of
thousands on these fake websites and
they don't even end up getting the real
nft
we've also seen the rise of a new breed
of crypto bots these guys are now not
only an expert at trading but they're
also experts at picking out the next big
nft
but more than all this likely the most
obvious sign of a massive bubble was
influencers creating their own nfts and
cashing out millions by shilling it to
their audience and the only way to
cleanse all this garbage is for the
entire sector to get obliterated and for
people to get bored and leave after that
we can finally start to see a true
innovation once again and unique
applications that are actually
beneficial
now you might be saying that the nfd
market has already gotten crushed given
that prices are down 80 across the board
but this is just the beginning you see
while nfts have crashed in value
relative to the dollar they haven't
crashed in value relative to crypto take
crypto punks for example each crypto
punk still costs 60-70 ether just like
it did in march and april so the entire
crash so far is solely due to the crypto
itself falling 70 ether used to be worth
over 300 000
but now it's worth less than 100 000
now popular nfts like crypto punks and
board apes may actually hold on to the
value in relation to crypto decently
well but the vast majority of nfts are
likely headed towards zero and as the
crypto bear market continues it just
becomes more and more likely that these
nfts start to lose value against crypto
as well and while this will no doubt be
a painful journey for nft hotlers i
think it's exactly what the market needs
before it moves on to the next phase of
growth and adoption
in the end we live in an extremely
technology driven world but even now
parts of our daily lives have yet to be
digitalized we still go through
mountains of paperwork when we transfer
ownership and basic ideas like driver's
licenses have yet to be digitalized
fortunately it seems like nfts are just
what we need to digitize these last
remaining portions of our lives with
that being said though nfds don't have
the best of reputations amongst everyday
people and it's easy to understand why
everywhere on social media we're
constantly being exposed to degenerates
who are gambling on random jpegs and
while some of them are making money the
whole situation it doesn't exactly give
you confidence and trust in the market
ideally people would just put all this
behind us and focus on the positive
attributes of nfts but this is never how
it works out with every revolution we
see a bunch of garbage enter the space
and a massive bubble forming before a
massive crash wipes out nearly
everything we saw it with internet
companies in the late 2000s and we saw
with evs nfts 3d printing and who knows
what else over the past few years
and now we're seeing all these sectors
getting destroyed and that no one knows
when exactly the pain will end but
eventually we will make it to the other
side and we will see through innovation
and growth maybe governments will start
issuing nft based ids and universities
will start handing out nfd based
diplomas who knows only time will tell
but in the meantime if you're wondering
what happened to nfts the answer is
nothing other than the cleansing that
it's so desperately needed do you guys
own an nft comment that down below
also drop a like if this video made you
look at nfps differently and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest a few video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
next one